There are over 2,000
individual firefly species,
all within the taxonomic
family of Lampyridae,
which is pretty easy to remember.
And these lightning bugs with
their flickering light shows
make summer nights feel all
the more magical and romantic.
But how did fireflies manage
to catch lightning in a bottle?
The answer is found in the bug's butt,
or more specifically in its abdomen,
in an organ called the lantern.
This organ is a set of
specialized light cells,
all encased in a translucent exoskeleton.
And those light cells are
where the magic happens:
the phenomenon of bioluminescence,
when a chemical reaction in
a living thing emits light.
Fireflies aren't the only
creatures that have this power.
Glowworms and certain
deep-sea fish species
are some of the creatures capable
of producing and emitting light.
But the firefly is probably
the Earth's most famous
bioluminescent species.
So what's happening inside
the firefly's light cells?
What's the secret to its glow?
In the 19th century, French
pharmacologist Raphaël Dubois,
working with bioluminescent clams,
discovered that there are
two essential components
to these creatures' light show.
He named them luciferin and luciferase,
based on the Latin term
lucifer, for "light-bringer."
Luciferin is the compound
that generates light,
and luciferase is the
enzyme that acts on it.
Today, we know that the
firefly's bioluminescent reaction
plays out like this.
A firefly diverts oxygen
to its light cells
through its tracheoles.
And those oxygen molecules
react to luciferin,
catalyzed with the help of luciferase
and energy in the form of ATP.
The luciferin then becomes
agitated and excited,
elevating its energy level.
And when the excited luciferin
drops back to its normal state,
it releases that energy
in the form of light,
creating the "fire" in fireflies.
It's a remarkable phenomenon
that's also remarkably efficient.
In a light bulb, 90%
of the energy consumed
is given off as heat,
with only the remaining
energy, a mere 10%,
given off as visible light.
In a firefly, on the other hand,
nearly 100% of the energy
is given off as light.
That luminescence, or "cold
light," as it's also called,
is produced in the light cells
and then focused by a
layer of reflector cells,
which direct that beam outward
through that translucent exoskeleton.
But why do fireflies do what they do?
As it turns out,
bioluminescence has a number
of evolutionary benefits,
helping certain marine species
lure prey to their mouths
or serving as a defense against predators.
Sara Lewis: Fireflies are beetles,
and so the juvenile
fireflies live underground.
So, we think that firefly light
first evolved as a warning.
It's like a neon sign that shouts out,
"Don't eat me, I'm toxic."
Narrator: But in adult fireflies,
the purpose is a bit more romantic.
Those yellow flashes lighting
up our warm summer nights
are actually part of the
fireflies' complex mating rituals,
with male fireflies attracting
female fireflies of the same species
by flashing a distinctive,
recognizable pattern.
So those lights twinkling around you,
switching on and off seemingly at random -
they're just the opposite:
a highly intricate, specialized form
of species-specific seduction.
Lewis: In North America,
males might flash,
like, just one flash.
Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, bleep,
another flash, wait, wait,
another flash.
Some species, the males
actually give paired flashes,
so they'll fly along and
then go bleep, bleep,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Bleep, bleep, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait.
And so on.
And so females who are
kind of hanging around
on grass down below can see these flashes,
and they can recognize a
male of their own species.
Narrator: But for all
the romance and magic
they add to our summer evenings,
firefly populations around
the globe are at serious risk.
Those finely tuned mating rituals?
Thanks to light pollution,
those love letters get a
little lost in translation.
Lewis: In areas where there's
a lot of bright lights,
it's been shown that it's
much, much more difficult
for the male fireflies to find the females
and for the females to see the flashes,
the advertisement flashes
of the male fireflies.
Narrator: And other
threats like habitat loss
and pesticide use have also
put the population at risk.
Lewis: Sadly, in many parts of the world,
there are other firefly species
that aren't doing so well.
In fact, they are flickering out.
And some of these fireflies are restricted
to a very specific habitat.
If that habitat goes away,
the fireflies disappear.
They can't live anywhere else.
Narrator: It's a story playing out
all over the planet and
across the animal kingdom.
But as Lewis explains,
education is absolutely
key to conservation
of fireflies and of all at-risk species.
Lewis: If fireflies disappeared,
a lot of the world's wonder
would disappear with them.
Would you wanna live in a
world without fireflies?
I would not.
Narrator: By increasing
awareness of these risk factors,
Lewis hopes to shine a little
light on firefly conservation,
ensuring that these little bugs
will be able to dazzle
us for years to come,
giving future generations the chance
to spend their summer nights
trying to catch lightning in a bottle.